c'est le lieu de tous les dangers
kharkiv en ukraine à moins de 40 km de
la frontière russe si vladimir poutine
attaque ce pourrait être la première
grande ville sous les bombardements
froid polaire et détermination des
habitants à ne pas se laisser faire
j'ai 73 ans mais si les russes à rien je
prendrai les armes et j'irai au front
dans le plus grand secret à l'abri des
regards des volontaires préparent cette
éventuelle offensive de mouscron
chansons nationalistes l'ukrainienne et
confection artisanale de couverture de
camouflage
ses filets cacheront les soldats
ukrainien et leur équipement dans les
tranchées une mission bénévole au nom de
la patrie
je suis une femme mon caractère n'est
pas celui d'une guerrière qui veut aller
se battre mais je ferai tout ce que je
peux pour aider mon pays et
mes actifs il y a aussi des ukrainiens
pro russe ils sont minoritaires mais
compte bien se faire entendre
cet élu par exemple est en direct via
son téléphone sur une télévision
nationale un rapprochement avec moscou
et refus d'une crème lié à l'otan qu'est
ce que l'otan nous apportera rien s'ils
ont tous ont un seul but installés ici à
kharkiv et des équipements militaires
pour viser directement moscou
une position contre l'amérique et contre
l'europe que ne partage pas du tout ce
réserviste de l'armée ukrainienne
ces enfants jouent sans un soupçon
d'inquiétude
pendant qu'il vérifie son paquetage
tout à fait prêts à combattre les russes
si les mobiliser
ni du moc la tige est ce que la russie
n'est pas une démocratie c'est un pays
totalitaire nous les ukrainiens sommes
bien plus proche des valeurs européennes
par exemple chez
après l'appel du président ukrainien des
milliers de volontaires s'entraînent à
travers le pays
atmosphère de veillée d'armes et
évaluation en urgence de l'état des
abris pour les civils
ici un sous sol d'immeuble
inspectés par les agents de la mairie
une alarme retentit rats pendant trois
minutes en cas d' attaque ce sera le
signe pour la population d'allumer la
radio ou la télé les messages diront
d'aller dans les abris
4000 abri pour une ville qui compte près
d'un million et demi d'habitants
attaque imminente dans plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines ou jamais les
habitants de kharkiv vivent dans cette
angoisse depuis des semaines suspendus
aux surenchères diplomatique